oh so good ah
dude he's so young oh wait never mind oh
my
god damn what when your temporal
resolution is only 24 frames per second
and you remove one of those frames the
gap
in motion becomes huge all right hold on
what is temporal resolution
thanks to vessi for sponsoring this
video they're actually running an early
black friday sale
so stick around to the end to figure out
how you can be a part of it hey welcome
back to another episode of stunt women
react we're here with amy johnston an
amazing actress and stunt woman she's
done incredible stuff
amazing fight choreography some really
solid hits and i can't wait
to see what kind of stuff she's going to
teach us today oh
illuminate the world of crazy action for
us
this is a clip that you are excited to
talk about yes i really like
the choreography and samurai feel in
raroni kenshin i think they did it
so well it flows really well i love it
this reminds me of 13 assassins yes
actually very similar this is nice
they did a really good job making it not
feel like there's a crowd just waiting
for their turn to
exactly like the putties i think we
talked about that last time
yes yes there's constant action going on
and camera's moving very well
the first thing that i noticed is
there's a ton of people and it's very
fast i don't know i was going with that
do you think the undercurrent is a good
start i do i do i think most action
films under crank you're wondering
what's called cranking is because they
used to crank the cameras so under
cranking just meant you'd go a little
slower but then when it's played back
faster everything moves faster so if you
want an actor to look a little faster
and the movements to be a little more
precise and faster you would under crank
it
i've never under cranked anything really
really i would just speed it up by like
in the edit see that's a common mistake
that a lot of people make i would love
to get into that i don't know if here's
the place
what do you mean here this is the place
this is definitely the best but we're
talking about like editing and hot keys
no no no we talk about the overall
philosophies here so why don't you just
film at 24 frames per second
and then speed it up later problem is
your temporal resolution net
hold on what is temporal resolution all
right 24 frames per second means that
for one second you have 24 images so
your temporal resolution
is 1 24th of a second you're capturing
action every 24th of a second got it
when you want to speed it up the only
way to do that is to pull some of those
frames out
and squish it together when your
temporal resolution is only 24 frames
per second and you remove one of those
frames the gap
in motion becomes huge so if you're
trying to do a smooth fight scene and
you're doing your thing and also you're
here then
now you're here but then it continues
moving smoothly it looks weird because
everything jumps
so if you want to speed things up you
can either natively record at a lower
frame rate so like 22 frames per second
then all those frames are evenly
distributed so you have no jumps my
whole thing was like shooting at 22 was
you're baking that in you no longer have
those extra two frames
yeah you're set and you're locked you
can't go back so if you want to not bake
it in the way to do that is to record at
a much higher frame rate say 48 frames
per second or 60 frames per second then
you can go to you know 15
faster 10 faster 25 faster so temporal
resolution is high enough
that when you remove those frames you're
not creating big gaps in motion that
stick out to the eye
unless you frame blend or interpolate
right unless you use optical flow
interpolation
which tends to actually work pretty well
okay cool all right we're on the same
page so
they probably under crank this then
it's interesting that they're doing a
fight scene without any blood yeah
either that's like a stylistic thing
i doubt it's a story thing right is it a
story thing i don't think it's a story
thing i think it was one of those things
where it was just like let's get this
big fight scene done in a short amount
of time we don't have blood for it it's
still gonna look cool yeah
but i would have loved some like sprays
of blood you know
that's the 13 assassins version yes
one of the biggest things that we've
learned here on stunt's react
when you set up something very
complicated you want to pre-visit your
stuff
so this fight scene here had to have
been previs right at some point maybe a
week before two weeks before
oh yeah for sure with scenes like this
there's definitely a lot of pre-visual
work especially with the
dp and director not just the stunt team
or the action
doing it together but also bringing in
the camera to be a part of the action
and it always ends up being way better
when the camera's involved because i've
been on shoots where
the director or dp both were like no no
we'll show up on the day
you guys do your work you guys do stunts
and then we'll come and shoot it because
we know how to shoot and it's like i
know you do i trust that you do
but also like you can be a part of the
action and make it look that much
better if you work with us i think it
always looks
way better when the camera work is tied
into the action like this
that's why you have like whole action
units right like chris chris cohen
yes and sometimes second unit action
directors
really know what they're doing so it's
it's nice when people really know how to
shoot for action you know a director has
a lot of responsibilities
having some good taste is probably one
of those top responsibilities you should
know like this is good that's bad but
knowing how to choreograph it and set it
up
is probably not one of the immediate
responsibilities of a director
which is why you want to hire an awesome
action team like yourself and you have a
sick coordinator
who can put together something like this
yeah i agree a lot of time directors
will kind of take control and
and do everything themselves but the
best directors allow everyone else
who they've hired to do their job i
agree you know like then we can all work
together beautifully
i've always seen these night fights in
movies and i was like ding ding ding
ding ding somehow like hitting the
knives against each other and never
getting cut
always seems so ridiculous so let's just
take it to the pinnacle of
ridiculousness let's see steven seagal
fight tommy lee jones you look familiar
i know you don't i i think you do
dude he's so young wait never mind
[Music]
none of this was choreographed i think
they choreographed the beat and then
they choreograph like okay stephen
you're going to come in
there'll be a cut here just fling those
hands around cut to an insert up slice
right do you think this was improv do
you think they just let seagal do what
he wants
like steven do your thing the actors are
taking lunch this is your time to shine
yeah bring it
dude see tommy lee stunt right there oh
that was him
check out these 720 he pulls off go
tommy
he hit his back on that table too yeah
very good
probably a little pad on oh definitely
but very good
was that a prop head oh yeah it looks a
little waxy
a little different did all that work for
like a 12 second cut away
worth it so what do you think this scene
compared to the improv scene with donnie
yen and killzone
they're kind of one of the same because
i don't know actually
no they're not at least this moment all
right let's hear it clint
let's hear it be mean to donnie yen
let's hear it no it's just that fight i
love donnie yen
donny i love you it's just the idea that
there's nothing of substance that's
actually happening it's not doing
anything for me it doesn't make me feel
anything when i'm watching the fight
they're just doing stuff they're just
waving their hands you know but it's
still
cool i mean i understand i'm not a fan
of people doing things just to do things
but like the style of this the colors
the talent
it's so good the whole fight scene as a
whole
is awesome it's just those moments where
they go like improv moments and they
just do that little like
swish swish no i i can see what clint's
saying it's like when you get improv
you lose a little bit of the story
purpose of the scene there is something
cool about seeing
two fighters square off with each other
and getting that improv moment kind of
gives you that
if you hit that point in the story it
works but the under siege fight
it's a cool heightening and energy but
the fight itself doesn't tell any story
whatsoever
i see the benefit to having a moment
like this if these guys are really good
and they both are like hey we want to do
this please go for it because you can
you have that in the edit you can use it
if you need it i think we've come to a
mutual understanding
hey guys what do you get when you
combine an ancient egyptian scholar
and a german u-boat a subscribe
did you just come up with that yeah of
course i just came up with it it's a
little rough still i'm working on my
delivery
that's like a popsicle stick joke if you
don't subscribe you're going to hear
more those
awful groaners in the next one so this
is one way to avoid that
since we're on the topic of knife fights
let's watch a really cool knife fight
scene
dude i loved this knife fight yeah it
was great
you guys have your minds blown uh yeah
all the breaking glasses cg
what really yeah there's no practical
glass and set being broken
oh wait boy really yep is that just for
ease of filming and
and safety yep so that's all cg look at
the way he hits it and it rumbles the
glass
and it's perfectly reflecting the
environment like with his that head
strike
is insane why would we not talk about it
very impressive all right vfx rs reacts
we'll do a glass episode
i love the ground struggles i love that
it feels messy like a lot of the
takedowns
there's like a push and pull and then
one person takes the other one down as
opposed to just like being so set up and
perfect it just feels more real that way
he pulls the knife out and he's coming
back he's like
it's not over
i love it i love that yeah that's not
keanu taking that hit is it i think so
oh no it doesn't need to be no it
doesn't need to be it's a great dropkick
i like i love this part i love this
throw throw through
i mean if i was that good at throwing
knives i would throw them
that's awesome yeah so good yeah
what was that it was a weird discount oh
wait wait oh what is that maybe he was
supposed to do
like do an arm break there or something
i'm sure it's legit well the choreo and
this is like
oh yeah 87-11 is great
that two-on-one is so good yeah there's
constant movement and flow
these stunt guys are killing it too oh
yeah rule number one is that your
stuntmen and some women have to make
your
actors look good right if your actor can
kind of throw a punch and they throw a
punch the stunned person has to really
sell that punch is the case where some
guys are making big enough actions that
keanu's focused smaller movements
read as him being professional as
opposed to him just not having a range
of motion at the stuntman yes
you're so right though there's such an
importance of how stumped people take
the reactions
because you can have an amazing fighter
but then if the stunt person doesn't
take the reaction properly or
as intense as they should it's not going
to look very impactful do you ever throw
your neck out from like selling hits
totally you have to do a lot of like
neck stretches before you do anything
i'm constantly hurting it sounds bad but
you get whiplashed a lot
especially from during like jerky
movements or wire work and stuff do you
find yourself
having soreness or like lingering issues
from the stunts that you do
yeah definitely we all have some battle
wounds i guess i've been pretty lucky so
far i had like a torn acl and a bunch of
hamstring things and you know little
issues but nothing terrible just lots
and lots of bruises
so what do you do for recovery do you do
any yoga or do you take any turmeric or
anything like that a lot of advil yes
yoga and turmeric are good
i hypervolt what's hypervault
i'm not sponsored by any of these so but
yeah lots of
lots of things that i do
so good that's right human skulls are
hard
i'll do this
[Applause]
dude it's like going down a roller
coaster ah so intense
all right so we talk about a lot of
different stunts here there's one type
of stunt that's hard to find
stunts with animals so if you know of
any good stunts with animals please
leave a comment below and of course
anything else you want to react to
you're welcome leave a comment for that
as well but you know let's spice it up a
little bit
did you guys see atomic blonde yeah i
did not i love the choreography
in this film for her she did a great job
with this
i like that she's getting hit also she
has to use certain movements because she
has many people against her there's back
and forth it just feels much more
grounded they're watching a character
try to solve a problem yeah and there's
emotions tied to her movements like that
is beautiful
and also a really important thing is you
can create choreography but you need to
create choreography that makes the actor
look good
she looks great with this movement this
powerful straight to the point movements
it's a testament to charlize's training
that she put in really went above and
beyond to make it look like she knows
how to move
you know she doesn't look janky when
she's moving it looks legit
this is much more grounded her movements
are very precise there's a story being
told between
every movement that they're doing she's
struggling when she jams a knife into
somebody she has to reinforce it because
she's not as strong as them and even
when she's winning she's still losing
for every action she makes there's a
reaction these little pieces are so good
in storytelling
yeah like you see them actually getting
winded and their energy
losing all their energy throughout this
fight this guy can barely stand up oh
damn dude what that's like
one of the minorities falls i've ever
seen amy have you ever had to take a
fall like this
i've done several stair falls but with
the stair falls that i've done they've
been like pushes into the stairs but
i've never just teeter-tottered like
that
how do you fight your instincts there's
so many things that your body does
how do you get rid of those instincts
it's just like a mindset thing i guess
you could practice some people do
practice stair falls with cushion stair
falls
get an idea of that before you can start
being safe but he's definitely padded up
and he's practiced this in some way it
seems
let's see where he hits first he's
hitting here and
maybe like his tailbone and he rolls
with it perfectly
i bet you the stairs are padded um i
don't know usually you can kind of tell
when they're padded
he's definitely padded you can tell
right here dang i'm glad we
stumbled across this fight scene because
that was incredible cool fighting and
there's some really cool stuff in atomic
blonde
i hope you guys enjoyed today's episode
as much as i enjoy these vessy shoes
because that's today's sponsor is vessie
when i go home for thanksgiving and
christmas i always bring my besties
because it's wet in atlanta and i want
to keep my feet
dry and they're the best shoe to do
exactly that so you hear water resistant
that's not waterproof
vessies are waterproof that means i
could spill water
all over these shoes and my feet would
be 100
dry which means they're super easy to
clean because you could just wash them
with water or toss them in a washing
machine and they're clean
we have all lost a favorite pair of
shoes to either mud or
water i'm going to pour one out for each
pair of shoes that i have lost
personally
now the way these shoes work they're
made from dimetex which is a dual
climate knit material which keeps you
cool in the summer and warm in the
winter they feel like socks and you can
slip them on and off your foot super
easily you don't have to untie the thing
you know i probably untie this thing
once every six months and they're
sustainably creative they're made with
less material so you're not wasting a
bunch of crap and also they're made from
zero animal products which means they're
vegan so here's how to get yourself a
pair of vessy shoes click the link in
the description
to make sure you guys make the black
friday sale but
if you missed that sale for whatever
reason you're eating too much turkey you
slept in too late you can use the code
corridor crew on their
site to save 25 so get yourself a pair
of vesti's keep your feet dry and never
lose your favorite pair of shoes to the
weather ever again
and i can get behind that if you are
interested in learning more about stunts
amy actually has a book out called how
to stunt in hollywood in fact the
audiobook version just dropped so you
should definitely go check it out we'll
have a link in the description below
we'll also link to amy's instagram if
you want to hit her up follow her
ask her questions whatever thanks for
watching everybody we'll see you next
saturday in the next react video
actually wait we'll see you maybe in the
middle of the week for the regular
recorder crew video we don't just upload
react videos we have other videos too
check them out